okay let's go
[Music]
yeah ladies and gentlemen
here we are once again
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right here we are back again special
bonus episode again trying this out
again this week
uh before i even get started though i
know people always ask me about my
gaming chair when i um
when i'm on twitch and i'm on twitch
daily eric griffin gaming
but uh i'm sponsored by ewin
ewin racing that's e-w-i-n
r-a-s-i-n-g dot com and they got these
great chairs i got this chair from them
it's awesome it's got great lumbar
support i sit in the chair a lot when
i'm gaming i'm there for hours sometimes
and my back never hurts it's very
comfortable it's easy to put together
and if you would like a chair you'll get
30 off when you use promo
code eric so check that out y'all
e win racing promo code eric anyways
welcome back to another episode of sort
of episode of riffing with griffin but
it's real world advice from a grown ass
man
just doing this separately um
so here we are um so let's just get
right into it i got some good ones this
week and i hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of uh riffing with griffin this
week too i had a vincent o'shanna
he hit on some hot button topics i see
the the comments are on fire
half the people hate him half the people
love him it's very polarizing but you
know we're in a polarizing time you know
with the
the election and trying to find out who
you know is a guy going to concede
is it going to work out the way who
knows what's going to happen so we're
still
playing it day by day we'll see what
happens on january 20th
if it all works out the way it's
supposed to but anyways vincent o'shawna
was on this week so make sure you check
that out
you know on the feed you know wherever
you listen to your podcast
uh wherever you you know listen to them
apple podcast
spotify all those kind of places my
podcast is there
and you know obviously here on youtube
also
uh at eric at eric griffin comedy i need
to change that to river with griffin but
you know we'll get into that i'm a
one-man show no producer i'm all by
myself
but anyways uh first question up on real
world advice from a grown-ass moon
i've got to use the mic real world of
ice from a grown-ass man
all right i don't know if that works out
now but anyways first one i got is i'm
23
and i feel like i'm rushing to try and
accomplish a lot before i reach 30
overwhelming help
well this is all about expectations and
where are they coming from you know like
sometimes we have pressure because of
our family you know that's i think
that's
where a lot of pressure comes from um
pressure comes from family and we they
they want you to
do certain things at a certain time you
know sometimes it's pressure to be in a
relationship sometimes it's pressure to
have kids sometimes just pressure to go
to college and school or
finish get a degree or or it's a stay in
the family business or whatever it might
be
sometimes you get a lot of pressure from
the family and you take that on and you
think that
excuse me you think that oh man if i'm
not doing exactly what they want me to
do
i'm failing or i'm not doing enough but
you know at a certain point you know
you're 23 years old yeah
even if you're living at home you know
you know you're you can drink
you can go to war uh you know you can
make your own decisions and make your
own choices
and so that's what you have to start
doing and sometimes in our life you know
it gets to a point in our life where
what our parents want for
us and what we want for ourselves
sometimes those things come to a fork in
a road and they go in different
directions
then you have to come back around and
show them hey i because of all the
things that
you taught me uh because of the
you know if you had good parents you
know what i mean uh
you know you could you know you show
them that you're making your own choices
and decisions
even if they don't agree with them but
you took their guidance and their
tutelage and you
you pursued this thing that you want to
do so
hey listen if you don't feel like you're
doing enough
you know take an assessment of yourself
and be like
like have you set goals have you
accomplished those goals because if you
haven't accomplished those goals then
maybe yeah maybe you haven't done enough
but
if you're just floundering around or or
if you're just like on a steady pace and
you feel like hey you're happy and
content with your life
don't put any undue pressure on yourself
but at the same time too though if
you're trying to strive for greatness
some people
strive under pressure situations like
that if you're telling yourself
i need to do more because that's how you
get yourself to like
really strive through and and maybe even
if you don't accomplish the
all these like fantastic goals that you
want that process of trying to
accomplish those goals you really are
living
so you know you're making yourself feel
overwhelmed you know so
i would just take i would just sit back
take a second
look at all the things that you have
done look at the things that you want to
do
and see if you're on the path to doing
those things
or look back and be like hey you know
what i've actually done quite a bit and
let me enjoy this
so take some time enjoy life plan things
out
um look at yourself take an assessment
and be like all right am i doing this
for me am i doing this for someone else
and is there a middle ground there and
there's no reason to be overwhelmed you
know
and if you do feel overwhelmed channel
that overwhelmness
into um accomplishing
even more if that's where you think you
need to be so
i think you're going to be fine you know
anybody that feels
like in a rush to try to accomplish
things they probably have big goals big
dreams big desires and you just you see
the end goal
but enjoy that process enjoy that
process of reaching that end goal
you're really gonna that's the living
man so good luck with that all right
next one are open
relationships ever a good idea
well like i don't know
an open relationship to me it takes
a real maturity
to get past the selfishness and
possessiveness that you
feel when you're in a relationship with
someone especially intimate
you really feel a sense of like this
person is
this is my person this this relationship
is mine and you really
you know and then like those
insecurities start kicking in if
you know if you know someone's with
someone else if you don't have a core
strong foundation of trust and
understanding with this person
you know how are you gonna you're not
gonna be okay with them being with other
people
i'm just looking at this practically i
mean just on face value i would say no
just on its face without on the surface
i would say no i don't think it's a good
idea
uh because it's like you know and then
you have people say like well
why do you need to be an open
relationship is this thing not enough or
are you not committed or why you even be
in a relationship
it's like you want to have your cake and
eat it too i mean
there's such a thing as polyamorous um
relationships
uh you know you know listen i'm sitting
in front of my computer right now let's
let let's
let's actually that's why i'm doing it
right here now
um let's look it up polyamorous
you know let's look it up let's look it
up
polyamory whatever however you say it is
the practice
of or desire for intimate relationships
with more than one partner
with the informed consent of all
partners involved
it has been described as consensual
ethical
and responsible non-monogamy
that's i don't even know what to say
about that but that's a lot but that's
what i'm saying you know
you know it's like you're saying you
want the other person
to understand that you're being with
other people
and they accept it they acknowledge it
they're saying they're okay with it and
you're also saying that you're okay with
it
i mean that's a lot to wrap your brain
around
if you're not ready to really delve deep
and really think about
all that that means then no i don't
think it's a good idea
and it's a lot to like being in one
relationship is a lot it's hard
you know it's it's challenging it's
demanding it's
you know you know to worry about
somebody else's happiness and
and their desires and making sure
they're happy and making sure you're
happy
it's a lot just with one person so
if you don't have the mental maturity
to deal with it emotionally
and even phys the physical demands as
well i don't think it's a good idea so i
don't even know the way i'm talking
about it you
probably not even thinking about it on
this level but there are people out
there that
are living this kind of lifestyle
polyamory so
you know i think it can work
but it doesn't work for most people and
i think the level that you have to be at
like i say
emotionally uh the maturity you have to
have
it it's on a it's a whole other level
that it's like why put yourself through
that so
i don't necessarily think it's a good
idea but hey
you do you boo good luck with that
all right here's another one is it
possible
to be more than friends with a girl
who's
unfortunately really damaged
okay let me stop here for a second um
because i forgot to say this in the
beginning and i usually say this in the
beginning but let me say it now
i'm just giving you guys my practical
common sense advice
but if you have some real issues real
problems anxiety depression
if you have any kind of sort of thing
that i
encourage you to go get therapy i
encourage you to go get help if you're
asking a question about a loved one that
is going through something difficult
and my advice to you is as always is to
seek out help because there are a lot of
services out there if you haven't
especially if you have insurance
and even if you don't there are some
places you can call there's some
resources you can look into
and i encourage that because there are
therapy is not a bad thing it's just a
way to help you organize your thoughts
a way to help you to organize your
thoughts with a professional
so you can trace the dots to see why you
feel the way
you feel that's what really what therapy
is at the core of it
they're not going to solve your problems
they're just going to help you
understand them and when you have
understanding it's an easier way to
it's easier just to deal with and or try
to deal with at least you have a
blueprint you know so i encourage that
with all of this
and i'm not pretending to be a
psychologist or a doctor or anything
like that
i'm just out here giving my advice but i
do encourage you all to get help
and so when i hear this question right
here you know is it possible to be
uh more than friends with a girl who is
unfortunately really damaged
i mean you have to ask yourself like you
know
you know it's like when you're in a
relationship isn't it best to be in a
relationship with someone who
is all there uh someone who is that
at the best version of themselves so
if you really care about this person
make sure that you know you don't care
about the person
or part of the reason why you care about
them is because they're damaged like is
there something about you that
you have this like i want to fix it
personality because you know i've been
like that in my past you know
uh when i went to therapy my the first
thing my therapist told me and it was
just like it really
shook me and it's why i stayed with this
particular therapist
she said i had a false sense
i had an exaggerated sense of
responsibility
an exaggerated sense of responsibility
and
it really shook me because it just means
that like you know i get people in my
life and i
and i feel like responsible for them i
feel like i'm supposed to like do more
than i really have to i take on
their issues and problems and i make it
like my problems and if they're not
doing well
i feel like i failed and that's really
an exaggerated sense of responsibility
it's like it's not my responsibility
people make choices you can help
and this just goes into like when you're
around people who are taking drugs or
drinking and
you know you feel like you like
you if you're not doing all that you can
do you're failing them
but it really boils down to hey they've
made a choice you've done the best you
can do and you have to have boundaries
you know what i mean you have to have
your boundaries so
that all that being said is when i hear
this question i just say
look if you're trying to be a friend if
you if you're having real feelings for
this person
i would imagine that you would want that
person to be
you know happy and healthy you would
want that person to be the best version
of their self making a choice in this
decision that is coming from a place
that they are in a stable situation and
they go
i am now stable i'm now feeling secure
and healthy
and now i want to bring you into my life
because you don't want to become
someone's crutch
or you don't want it to be that they're
just because when i hear
really damaged i hear someone who
probably has a lot of trust
issues and that's something that they're
gonna need help
overcoming and and maybe a romantic
situation is
not the best thing at first
you know or maybe it's not healthy for
that person or your
or for you for that matter in that in
that situation so
i don't know i'm really torn on this one
um i think you i think it is possible
but how you approach it um
that's the important part you know how
do you approach it if you're ready if
you're ready to be
really patient and understanding and
build trust for this person so they can
be the best version of themselves
then yeah if you're willing to do all
that but if it's just about like
you know you have feelings and you have
intimate feelings for this person you
know you're if you're if you're
ask yourself too are you attracted to
damaged people
do you want damaged people around you
does it make you feel good
because i was starting to think about
that even for myself like why are a lot
of my friends
these people that are like they need me
do i
need to be needed so really like like
assess yourself
too like don't put it all on this person
don't put it all on this girl
think about you like huh am i am i
attracting this because you don't want
that either
so again it just takes a lot of maturity
and understanding and
it's not easy man so if you really care
about this person then
make sure you're you're you're in it for
the right reasons and you take the steps
and be patient
along the way to build trust for her
because i don't
you didn't go into details about what
the damage is
but i can just only imagine i just
thinking about people that i've met and
and and the damage that they've gone
through and i it's hard
you know it's hard sometimes to even be
friends with people like that
once you start to really have have your
boundaries up and start to
make sure you look out for you you know
because you got to look out for you and
your well-being
because remember you know it's just like
being on an airplane you can't
help anyone with their gas mask until
you put it on yourself first
so anyways good luck with that situation
all right here's another good one and
this is a present for what's going on in
the times right now and i
um i thought uh this would be a good one
to answer
uh my friends think i'm racist just
because i support trump
what should i do and he's mexican by the
way he says
i mean this is like what's wrong to me
with our country right now in the first
place it's very polarizing politics are
very polarizing
the fringe of each party has
hijacked it and made it like this
hyper understanding of what being a
conservative and a liberal republican a
democrat even means
and then you have this guy who will you
know
on the surface some of the things he was
saying and doing and encouraging and not
saying the things he didn't say
uh you know he he very much was like if
you came across as he was just for the
republican party and no one else
and then you have people who you know
they
you know they they label that always
racist and all this but
at the core republican values
they're not bad for america they're not
bad for families they're not bad for
business they're not bad for you
i mean that's why we have checks and
balances in the system
there's a lot of things about the
democrat what the democrats stand for
and
are going for there's a lot of things
there too that are great for the country
i think when these two sides work
together and then there's
uh a compromise between the parties we
get the best out of them
but you shouldn't feel bad for being
like hey i
i support what
the guy was what the what the guy stood
for behind what he stood for because
he actually did accomplish a lot of
things i mean african-american
unemployment latino unemployment
female unemployment was down there's a
lot of things that you can look at
there is a checklist of things you can
go well these are the things that happen
during the trump presidency they're just
outweighed by the you know the media
the scrutiny that he got and and and
some of the things he said and how he
carried himself
all that stuff outweighed all of this
other stuff so
look 70 something million people voted
for the guy you know the other side
wants to say those people are stupid
but i tell you what you know all the
people that think you're racist
you need to ask them tell me something
that they they they know about
biden or any democratic
congressman senator like what do they
actually know is what i'm saying
a lot of these people that talk smack
about politics
and they talk smack about trump they
know
they know nothing about their own party
they couldn't tell you whose
their congressmen are their senators are
they couldn't tell you anything
they couldn't tell you what the policies
are they you know those are not the ones
you need to listen to
those are just people that just like
they're just oh
you racist you're a racist they can't
even tell you why they think you're a
racist
so don't feel bad about it just put them
on put it on them you know
just put it on them why am i a racist
tell me
and then they'll say like well because
he's racist all right tell me why he's
racist
you know like they won't i trust me they
won't have an answer
they won't have an answer uh most people
most people just uh you know they get
their news from twitter
they get their news from places that are
in sound bites
but the actual facts and evidence and
when you delve deep and have a real
conversation a real back and forth
if you can have that with those people
you it'll be okay
you know they're most of us are
reasonable and understanding
so you just need to find that within
your friends and when you
when they say that to you just go do
they know you
you know what i mean like like when
somebody calls you a racist
if they're supposedly your friend they
know you're not racist
it's like if you know what i mean it
makes no sense for them
to to to say that you know so i wouldn't
worry about it
i wouldn't let it say not worry about it
but i wouldn't let it bother you
the ones that are calling you racist
like if all your friends think you're
racist
you know it's like come on i'm sure not
all of them think you're racist
i don't think you're racist you know i
think we're all misinformed about things
but if you have your reasons and you can
articulate them this is why i support
this
and you can articulate them who can who
can knock you for that
if it makes sense to you you can make it
make sense to them and they can just
agree to disagree instead of it being
like this
polarizing thing where now if you
support one side you're this
and you support the other side you're
this we got to stop demonizing each
other
and just try to find some middle ground
and some understanding
so good luck with that my friend
all right so i have a couple of videos
um
and let's see i actually have three
videos
let's see what we got here here's our
first one
how's it going my name's kyle my
question is
should i move to thailand once kovid
lives
i live in san jose california very
expensive very boring here
i actually met you i used to work at the
san jose improv you're one of the
coolest comedians besides joe coy
anyways a little back story my mother
passed away two years ago which
really broke my heart she told me before
she died she never traveled so i
traveled the world
somehow it landed me in thailand i fell
in love with the people
and lifestyle and again i could keep my
american wage i could work all i need is
wi-fi
and then my my dad and my dog died
last christmas so there's nothing here
but my sister and her kid they're looked
after
should i stay in america or should i
move to thailand
let me know man thanks
all right um man first thanks for
reaching out to me um and and the words
you said about me i appreciate
that and it's good to see you again
brother um
sad i mean this is like a lot to unpack
here and
i'm sorry for your loss um but i do
understand
what you did you know it's like my own
personal story is
you know my mom wanted to be a concert
pianist when she was
growing up and coming from a third world
country and
she never got to pursue that and that
she had me
and so i got into entertainment and
part of my motivation to like make it
and succeed was for her to be like you
know you never got to
live your artistic dream so here i am
living mine
so i get that energy of like your mom
never got to travis you're like ooh
you know what let me travel one
for my mom's sake and also even for
yourself to be like
hey this is something actually on my
bucket list of things like
let me take care of things so i don't
end up like what happened to your mom
you know
so again sorry for your loss and i think
that you you made a good choice
you know you're living your life and
that's the best thing you can do
the loss in life is tragic and
we're never going to necessarily get
over these things and the way we do is
we just
work through it through time and and we
honor them
so i respect that honor your mom by
traveling and doing that
now you went to thailand and
you loved it don't feel bad about that
if you have the means and the
wherewithal and you have it all planned
out you got money in the bank and you
could keep your job
all these things that you said it sounds
to me like you want to go but you don't
have
you know the people that you had before
your mom and your dad and
and the people to be like to bounce off
of i don't know if you have
a bunch of you know a lot of friends or
if you have a few friends or even one
good friend that you could just be like
hey i want to do this because because it
feels to me like you want to do it
so my advice to you is just do it man
take the chance take the shot
you loved it like you said you love the
people and then and then
you feel like you have nothing here
anymore your sister and her kid are
taken care of
you'll always be able to visit you can
facetime you can google talk you could
you know there's so many ways to keep in
contact with people these days
and you know i have my big brother from
big brothers of america
program this is somebody i've known for
over 40 years you know he was a
a father figure in my life you know
he fell in love with a thai woman and
he's been he goes to thailand
for six months at a time even to this
day so i know that people
fall in love with that lifestyle and
they fall in love with that place and i
say to you like you know hey if you're
feeling it
go do it you know and feel happy about
it you know put a smile on your face
that you're like
actually like i said you're honoring the
people
that have passed away by making sure
that you are living the best life you
can
so
to you and good luck
man good luck
all right here's another one
here's another of our videos
hey eric um thank you for the advice
i have a sister that is really negative
and i usually try to
eliminate her from my life but my 84
year old mother guilt me into
trying to have a relationship with her
so any advice that you are willing to
give would be
greatly appreciated thank you
okay this is tough i mean first i'll say
this i mean the toughest thing about
family is we don't get to choose them
that's why we choose our friends that's
why we end up sometimes having better
relationships with people that we
went to school with uh people that we
have like interests with uh people that
you know we've met along the way and we
have these strong bonds you know it's
like
people go into the military and those
people become their brothers
people that you fight with people that
you go to war with people that you like
you know
literally and figuratively uh
those are the people that become the
most important people in our lives and i
get that
easier for me to say too because i'm an
only child because i've never even
experienced having
a brother or sister so i've tried to
manufacture that with close
friends and i have i have some really
close
really close bonds and friendships with
people and i and i
i treat them like they're my brothers uh
family so
i get the pull of family you know but
it's just one of these things that you
know it's like
at a certain point i i know that feeling
of like
i don't want this person in my life
anymore because it they're not doing
anything for me and it's just a negative
mess
so you can either try to work on that
and maybe you have
i don't know but you have to work on
your response first that's what you have
to do
you know if you're letting this person
get to you
you have to ask yourself why does this
bother me why is this person getting to
me
why do i care so much about this
situation deal with those
issues because you really want to get to
a point where you're indifferent
you know when you're indifferent it's
like it's like the opposite
some people think the opposite of love
is hate it's not
love and hate are so similar they're
they're still
based in like really strong emotions the
opposite of love and hate is
indifference
when you could just be like oh yeah huh
okay
whatever no problem all good
and it just doesn't bother you at all so
if you can get to a point where your
sister just
doesn't bother you anymore you might be
able to actually heal that relationship
or at least be able to be like hey
you're being negative again
and i don't like it and then just and
it's like it don't matter what
what she comes with you at no matter
what she says you know you have to find
a way to
overcome your feelings about it so then
you can now
maybe heal that relationship or help her
with whatever's going on with that and
in terms of like for your mom i get that
and that's why you should do it for your
mom too so you don't want to be
resentful
like you don't want to have resentment
for your mom because you already have
feelings about your sister that you're
just like i'm tired of this woman
but you don't want to resent your mom
because she's making you do this thing
no do it for your mom because it makes
her happy
so therefore also make yourself happy by
releasing yourself from these
demons that you have about your sister
so that's my advice there and uh
you know good luck my friend good luck
last one last one here we go
yo what's good griffin um my question to
you is
was something that somebody can do if
they never had a strong
foundation foundational support
uh for a decision that somebody makes or
family members never really uh had your
back on a goal that you've been striving
towards
or something that somebody can do
mentally to kind of
point them in the right direction less
okay um so the real question is
i want to read it too is that what do
you do if your family doesn't really
support your decision streams and goals
well this reminds me of the question
that i had earlier you know it's like
sometimes your parents your family's
idea of what they want for your life
uh get you a fork in the road of the
ideas and values that you want
in your life and it's really about how
you
feel about it like if you think about it
right now it just ain't really about
like
your parents and whoever not supporting
you it's really about
how you feel about them not supporting
you
and that hurts it doesn't feel good
you're feeling like oh man i would
really like you to support me and
they're not
so that's really the issue but so the
thing you really should think about is
just
you know how you could do it for them is
to be successful and my own example is
when i told my mom when i was younger
that i wanted to be a comedian
she was not happy she just wasn't she
didn't think i would make it
it just was one of those things where
she was like ugh you know i know it and
she didn't tell me this until later you
know
but she was trying you know it like i
just did look on her face and the things
she would say to me i knew that this is
not what
she wanted for me but it wasn't until
she
came to a show that i had i had this
like it was like i took an
acting class it was it was a comedy
acting class and we had a showcase
and she was sitting in the crowd
watching me
and she was she i remember she telling
me this you know i just was watching
the other people how they were laughing
at you and the things that they were
saying like oh that that guy's really
funny
and it's the moment that she realized oh
wow i guess you really are good at this
uh i guess i have to support you you
know what i mean or
you know you know i changed her mind so
that's all you really can do
is like you know if this is your goal
your desire your dreams this is what you
want to do
to accomplish no one no one should be
able to make you feel bad about it and
your energy towards accomplishing that
it will be infectious
you know and i understand that you
want that support and you want and you
feel like
you need that but you know what you're
not gonna get it
you're not gonna get it so you have to
go out and prove it to yourself and
prove it to them
and then slowly but surely you will win
them over and if you don't
in that process you're gonna accomplish
goals and dreams that are gonna make
you happy because it's your life
family get in the way of that sometimes
circumstances get in the way of that
sometimes you know
pandemics get in the way of that
sometimes but
how we feel the choices that we make
how we cope how we deal with our own
demons
about these things that is going to help
you
feel better and and
just live a a full life you know
so my advice is to work on you
that's my advice my advice is to not let
how they feel about it
affect you as much as it does
keep your eyes on the prize and you're
gonna show them
this is why i did this and if they love
you
they're gonna see it and be like well
damn
wow i didn't you know they're gonna
realize they're the ones that had the
doubt
but don't make them right by you having
doubt
so good luck with that my friend
right guys that's all we got for uh
today
for uh real world advice from a grown
ass man i'll be doing it every week
look out for my instagram post that's
eric griffin on instagram
i like to do it like that i do it pretty
quick um
i really should just have an email uh i
need to
make an email on myairgriffin.com to for
people to send me
emails and if you do you know you can
if you want to send an email to me eric
eric griffin.com
just please put advice in the um
in the in the subject and make sure you
send me a short video that
you know that i can just easily download
and play if you want to play video
if not just type your words out nicely
and or wait for my instagram post that i
put up every week
when it's time and just get it out there
i wish i can get to every single one i
try to answer some of them on instagram
you've seen that if you follow me um
and and if i didn't get to yours i'm
sorry uh but hopefully some of the words
i said to other people
can help you too and i'm just trying to
spread love that's all it is
i'm doing this because i feel like you
know i like connecting with people and
we're all
trying to connect in our own way so you
know
it's just my advice it doesn't i don't i
don't think i'm right about everything
i'm just giving you my advice
if you say oh you know i don't agree
with that but thank you for you know
the sentiment of what i'm trying to do
is just you just spread some good
good cheer good joy and you know my
40-plus years of living here's the
things that i have to say so
i do appreciate you guys listening and
watching and i hope you appreciated this
bonus episode of riffing with griffin
episode 107
real world advice from a grown ass man
and make sure you check out
this week's episode with uh the funny
comedian actor vincent o'shanna
and you catch me daily on twitch at eric
griffin gaming
and on youtube i put videos up on
youtube also eric griffin gaming on
youtube as well
thank you for watching and i'll see you
guys next week
you